THE RUNOFF ELECTION IS SET FOR
JANUARY 5TH.
BRIAN: AS GOVERNORS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY BEEF UP RESTRICTIONS,
OUR NEXT GOVERNOR SAWS HIS
STATE, TEXAS, WILL NOT SHUT
DOWN.
STEVE: TEXAS REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR
GREG ABBOTT WHO’S HAILING THE
ARRIVAL OF A NEW CORONAVIRUS
AUNT BODY TREATMENT IN THE STATE
AS WELL.
GOVERNOR, YOU’VE GOT AT LOT
GOING ON, DON’T YOU?
>> YOU KNOW, STEVE, WE HAVE A
LOT GOING ON, BUT I’M A LITTLE
BIT DISTRACTED BECAUSE I STILL
HAVE THE IMAGE IN MY MIND ABOUT
BRIAN’S DELTOID THAT HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT 30 MINUTES AGO.
[LAUGHTER]
PROVEN BRIAN LOOKING FORWARD TO
THE SHOT, WAS MY POINT.
>> SHOT.
AND, LISTEN, THE SHOT COMING.
STEVE, GOING BACK TO YOUR
COMMENT AND WHAT WE BEGAN DOING
LAST WEEK WAS WE BEGAN THE
DELIVERY OF THESE ANTIBODY
THERAPEUTICS, THE FIRST ONE
DELIVERED LAST WEEK IS THE ONE
BY ELI LILLY.
OVER THE WEEKEND THE REGENERON
ANTIBODY THERAPY, THE SAME ONE
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP TOOK, HAS
NOW BEEN AUTHORIZED FOR
EMERGENCY USE.
WE WILL SOON BE DELIVERING THAT.
HOWEVER, GOING BACK TO THE E I
LIE LILY ONE, GOING TO ALL OF
THESE HOT SPOTS THAT WE’RE
SEEING THIS TEXAS WHETHER IT BE
EL PASO, LUBBOCK AND SO MANY
OTHER PLACES, THIS THERAPY IS
GOING TO BE ABLE -- NOT GOING TO
BE, IS ALREADY AVAILABLE.
WE GET WEEKLY ALLOTMENTS WHERE
WE ARE INCREASING THE AMOUNT OF
THIS AUNT BODY THERAPY.
AND WHAT THIS DOES, IT ALLOWS
PEOPLE TO RECOVER AS QUICKLY AS
WHAT YOU SAW THE PRESIDENT
RECOVER.
AND IT KEEP PEOPLE OUT OF
HOSPITALS SO WE WILL BEGIN TO
SEE HOSPITALIZATIONS DECLINE.
AINSLEY: SOMEONE ASKED ME
RECENTLY SAID SAY THEY HAVE THE
ANTIBODIES AND DO I STILL HAVE
TO FOLLOW THE RESTRICTIONS SINCE
I’VE HAD IT, RECOVERED AND HAD
THE ANTIBODIES, AND I SAID, GOOD
QUESTION.
CAN YOU ANSWER THAT FOR US?
>> SO WHEN IT COMES TO BOTH THE
ANTIBODIES AS WELL AS THE
ONCOMING VACCINES THAT, AS YOU
SAW ANNOUNCED WILL SOON BE
DELIVERED MAYBE AS SOON AS THREE
WEEKS FROM NOW, IT WILL ALLOW
PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO TRAVEL OR
INTERACT OR DO COMMON DAY
ACTIVITIES WITHOUT THE SAME
CONCERN OF GETTING COVID AS
WOULD HAVE EXISTED BEFORE THESE
MEDICINES BECAME AVAILABLE.
BRIAN: YEAH.
I GOT A TEXT MESSAGE THE OTHER
DAY FROM THE BLOOD BANK SAYING
IF YOU KNOW ANYBODY THAT HAS THE
ANTIBODIES, THEY NEED ’EM FOR
TREATMENT.
I HAVEN’T HEARD THIS IN A WHILE.
MEANWHILE, HERE ARE YOUR CURRENT
RESTRICTIONS IN TEXAS,
GATHERINGS OF MORE THAN 10
PEOPLE PROHIBITED IN MOST
CIRCUMSTANCES, STATEWIDE MASK
ORDER INSTITUTED WITH SOME
EXCEPTION, BARS AND RESTAURANTS
AT 75%.
KNOW WHAT YOU’RE DOING?
GOVERNOR, YOU’RE GIVING PEOPLE
GUIDELINES, BUT YOU’RE NOT
UNTILING THEM WHAT TO DO.
YOU’RE SAYING THIS IS THE BEST
WAY TO KEEP SAFE, BUT I DON’T
WANT TO DESTROY EVERY BUZZ IN MY
STATE. -- BUSINESS IN MY STATE.
WHY IS THAT THE BETTER WAY TO
GO?
>> BECAUSE, BRUIN, ALONG --
BRIAN, ALONG THE COURSE OF
DEALING WITH THE PANDEMIC, WE’VE
ALL LEARNED WHAT WORKS AND DOES
NOT WORK.
ONE THING GOVERNMENT DOES NOT
NEED TO DO MICROMANAGE THE LIVES
OF EVERYBODY, AS YOU POINT OUT.
WE SET BROAD-BASED GUIDELINES
THAT LEAD TO GOOD PRACTICES
WITHOUT KNEW E COMANAGING IT.
ANOTHER THING I’VE MADE CLEAR IS
NO MORE LOCKDOWNS IN THE STATE
OF TEXAS.
AND I WILL TELL YOU THIS, THE
VALUE THAT SYMPTOM PEOPLE PLACE
UPON LOCKDOWNS IS MISPLACED.
IF YOU LOCK PEOPLE DOWN, IT’S
GOING TO PUT THEM INTO CONFINED
AREAS WHERE THEY CAN TRANSMIT
COVID JUST AS EASILY WITHOUT
PROTOCOLS AND WHAT WE’VE FOUND
IN TEXAS AS WELL AS LS WHERE IS
ONE OF THE LEADING PLACES WHERE
PEOPLE DO TRANSMIT COVID ARE IN
THESE PRIVATE GATHERINGS.
SO LOCKDOWNS ARE OVERVALUED.
STEVE: GOVERNOR, THE GOVERNOR OF
OREGON, A WOMAN BY THE NAME OF
KATE BROWN, SAYS, HEY, IF YOU
SEE ANYBODY BREAKING ANY OF OUR
STATE’S SUGGESTIONS AND
GUIDELINES, CALL THE COPS.
IS THAT THE WAY THEY SHOULD
HANDLE THAT, CALL THE COPS IF
YOU SEE SOMEBODY WALKING AROUND
WITH NO MASK?
>> I GOTTA UNTIL YOU, I THINK
THEY MAY HAVE SOME FOURTH
AMENDMENT CHALLENGES THERE.
BUT ALSO I HAVE TO POINT OUT THE
IRONY.
IF I UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY,
OREGON JUST LEGALIZED HEROIN AND
MAYBE COCAINE.
SO IT’S OKAY TO HAVE HEROIN AND
COCAINE BUT NOT TURKEY FOR
THANKSGIVING.
THAT IS UN-AMERICAN, IT JUST
DOES NOT MAKE SENSE.
AINSLEY: GOOD POINT.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, GOVERNOR.
HAPPY THANKSGIVING.
>> Y’ALL TOO.